there are plenty of questions we can
give you a why for it why were you
T-boned at the intersection because you
ran the light
okay there's no end of situations for
which the why question has a completely
legitimate answer that we're all
satisfied with it becomes an issue if
you try to get take a philosophical step
and then try to explore why as the
consequence of intent in so doing you
are handing intent to things that might
have no intent at all and therefore you
are forcing an intent where there might
not have otherwise been one you're
creating a dragon and then chasing the
dragon you created the dragon correct
and you want to give meaning and
significance to the existence of the
Dragon you created
where there was never a dragon there to
begin with